kassim du casino du typische suren
tochter eines suren so'n scheiß dir und
deinem propheten ins maul du sohn einer
räudigen hündin lachen als befreiung von
der unerträglichkeit dieser texte
leserbriefe an journalisten deren namen
fremd klingen sie wollen sich nicht zu
opfern machen lassen sieht sie ihn
lieber mit ihrer show durch die lande
wir spiegeln das was ist und übrigens
wir kommentieren das auch nicht im
grunde genommen tragen wir nur vor was
vorhanden ist
es geht darum der öffentlichkeit zu
zeigen womit man es zu tun hat wenn man
von rassistischen briefen spricht wenn
man von ressentiments sprich wenn man
von verachtung groll hass dem guten
alten hass m spricht lieber herr uhren
sohn zur fremdartiger name verrät die
persönlich sind absolut ungeeignet
sarrazin kritische artikel zu verfassen
verletzend entwürdigend sind die
zuschriften aber verharmlost man sie
nicht indem man die fremdenfeindlichen
texte zur show verarbeitet das passiert
keinen keinem von uns dass er so ein
brief bekommt und dann lacht sondern
natürlich geht einem das nahe und wenn
man zum beispiel online einen kommentar
zu einem bestimmten thema schreibt und
es kommen 500 kritische bis verhetzende
kommentare innerhalb von zwei stunden
dann ist es einfach kein spaß
es wird auch kein spaß durch das was wir
hier machen die hass mails sind ernst
gemeint
ihre verfasser stammen aus allen
sozialen schichten durch das gemeinsame
vorlesen entfalten die texte ihre
absurdität und unfreiwillige kuhn
ich habe nichts gegen muslime aber
muslime bringen nur unheil über die welt
schalten sie mal den fernseher ein lesen
sie zeitung ja nur ihre eigenen artikel
rassismus und vorurteile offenbaren sich
unverstellt dieser hält poetry spiegelt
die situation in deutschland
wie aber steht es mit solcher
beleidigungs postiert zu lande und
ausland sorgen machen um nicht weinen zu
müssen
2014 erhielt die gruppe in deutschland
für ihren einsatz als performa den
sonderpreis als journalisten des jahres
was hier funktioniert in dieser show die
wir entwickelt haben ist dass wir das
verwandeln in einen akt der katharsis
und dass wir uns von dem scheiß reinigen
und aus scheiße gold machen sozusagen
zum abschluss was persönliches die
endlich sterben mussten
tatsächlich gibt es nix ekelerregende
riss als dichter verfickte elende
inkompetente drecks [ __ ] hiermit
spreche ich eine fatwa gegen dich aus